[Music]
foreign
watching The Press preview a first look
at what is on the front pages time then
to see what's making the headlines with
the political editors of the guardian
and the Sun papakura and Harry Cole who
will be with us from now until just
before midnight welcome to both of you
so to the front page is then a shorter
than usual selection explain why in a
moment the mail reports that the
international monetary fund is
predicting that Britain will have the
weakest growth of all the major
economies this year with output
shrinking by 0.6
the Metro leads with a denial from the
Kremlin of an allegation by Boris
Johnson that Vladimir Putin threatened
to have him killed in a missile strike
the times reports that schools face
chaos over tomorrow's teacher strikes
that's tomorrow meaning Wednesday of
course newspapers are a day ahead
because unions have told their members
not to say whether they'll be in work or
not the sun carries allegations that a
Chelsea footballer used a racial slur in
a video on social media the Financial
Times International Edition has worded
the EU aiming to compete with U.S
infrastructure investment by offering
tax credits to be put towards green
initiatives and the star on a roll you
might say with an in-depth report on the
nation's lavatory paper preferences well
a reminder that by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
slightly fewer of them as I said because
there is an embargoed story so the
papers aren't releasing them to us yet
anyway
biblical and Harry coll are here let's
kick off with what we have um Pippa
firefighters now voting for strikes this
is inside the Sun hold on a minute I'm
just checking it's not written by Harry
no it's not I'm okay to go to you
um yes no no end in sight uh certainly
of this winter of discontent
yes this is the latest public sector
public service to uh go on strike we've
obviously got the first teacher strike
on Wednesday after talks with Julian
Keegan the education secretary broke
down we've got more real stroke strikes
with both aslef and rmt later on this
week
um Wednesday in particular is a big day
for walkouts because of the this is
basically coordinated action in response
to the um the anti-strike legislation
that the government uh sort of remaining
stages in the Commons tonight
um but the story of the Sun and across
the other papers is the is the latest
action which of course is the fire
brigades Union which is organizing has
balloted for strike action for the the
first time in 20 years I mean I'm old
enough certainly to remember the green
goddesses and the fact that the Army was
drafted in under the last the last time
the the firefighters went out on strike
um and writing about that story then the
fbu is saying that they're they're
walking out because basically they've
had a 12 drop in real terminal earnings
I was um since um 2010 I think it is no
sorry yes it's 2010 and that one in five
firefighters jobs has been cut I mean
it's a story which is based very
familiar to us
um from other public services over the
last few months we've heard similar uh
reasons being given by for example
health care workers nurses and so on
that they face real terms Cuts in their
income
um obviously with soaring inflation
those payments that they have received
haven't haven't kept up to peace with
those and they're really struggling out
many people with cost of living crisis
um other sectors as well the health
sector obviously is not just about pay
it's also about retention and the
feeling that people don't want to work
in the sector which is uh which is
obviously a huge problem for the NHS
which is facing many other problems at
the moment and in fire with one in five
jobs Cuts there's a real feeling amongst
um amongst firefighters that they and
the control room staff that they're
basically having to do more for Less
when the pressure on them is is
increasingly intense so it's you know
these strikes across the border show no
sign of abating the government strategy
is just talking at the moment we haven't
seen that deal that we're expecting to
come forward for health workers
um it looks very much that like there's
a stalemate in discussions and we're not
going to see any movement from either
side soon yes well teachers uh say
um their issue is retention to not just
pay uh gaps in the system there as well
and the time suggesting that actually
it's really difficult for head teachers
to plan on Wednesday because
um the union has asked teachers not to
say if they are striking I did put this
to the National Education Union
um uh joint General Secretary this
evening but anyway
um Harry tell us about the teachers and
uh what was a half hour meeting
apparently with Jillian Keegan today
yeah I mean the government's line is
it's currently holding that they're not
going to be reopen any pain negotiations
from last week uh so from last year
sorry I think perhaps the the idea that
the unions are floating tonight I think
when you in your interview perhaps a
multi-payer deal or discussing next
year's pay and uh perhaps um a you know
a sort of minimum guaranteed rise for
next year's pay negotiations I suspect
will be where somewhere where sort of
Landing zone is for these strikes if
there is going to be any breakthrough in
talks but no sign of that anytime soon
the government has all signaled they're
willing to talk about next year's pay
and perhaps speed up the pay review
boards process which starts begins
really in sort of spring where sort of
Treasury set budgets and departments
work out how much money they've got
that's then passed on to pay review
bodies who then negotiate and work out a
a pay offer but obviously that's for
next year so
um this is going to carry on rolling on
and as we saw with the fire brigades
this is quite contagious public sector
strikes tend to be like that if one one
sector sees perhaps if any movement on
theirs or perhaps getting a better deal
or by even getting around the table not
no sign of that yet more and more
sectors are going to strike for the
problem for the government it seems to
be a little bit like they're losing
control and this is why I think the
demonstration is being debated in the
house is needed because the sort of
sectors we're seeing now on strike are
the blue light Services the firefighters
and the ambulance drivers and nurses and
that minimum service
legislation would bring us in line with
our nearest socially Progressive
European neighbors
um that have stricter strike rules that
basically say yeah you can walk out sure
but you also can't leave people dying on
the curb
and yet people say you know if you lose
the power to withdraw your labor you'll
know better than a slave so that's why
this is so you're not you're not losing
you're not losing the power to withdraw
your labor you're losing the power to
make withdraw your labor make a protest
but also your your guaranteeing that if
you work in a sector that is life
dependent you you you work out on your
shift patterns how you make sure there
is a minimum service I think it's very
telling tonight actually the teachers
have joined the ambulance workers in
being quite disruptive the ambulance
unions that is have been quite
disruptive in leaving it right to the
last minute and to to have been to make
it as hard as possible for contingency
planning to try and keep as many schools
open and as many children in education
as possible because not don't forget not
all teachers are out not all ambulance
drivers are out not everyone is striking
but those that do are trying to make it
as hard as possible for services to
continue which um you know kind of says
oh it might be yeah well I think the
firefighters the earliest were likely to
see strikes is the 20 23rd and actually
on the back of this ballot they're going
to go back and speak to their Employers
in the hope of striking a deal so it's
not like they're launching into
immediate action and I should just say
that even though there is not a formal
minimum service legislation uh obviously
that's what the government's trying to
push through at the moment across the
health across the health sector and
particular nurses and a e staff they had
they volunteered their own minimum
service
um requirements during those strikes
days and ambulance staff who actually
got a lot of flack for not coming up
with the national Collective minimum
service level which obviously would have
been better to have a national one but
they did strike Regional ones with their
own NHS and they're in individuals
over it hours before the walkouts but
the but regardless they still they still
put one in place and what their argument
is is that they if they can't strike it
is effectively because they're drawing
the right to strike because they could
potentially be sacked
um or sued by their employers should
they do so do should they do that so
it's effectively Banning their right to
strike
their argument is the service is no
better currently at the moment than yeah
we had we had average waiting times of
19 minutes for an ambulance
legacies you know their whole point is
that they want the service to be safe
and currently it is unsafe regardless of
whether they're striking or not
it's a bit of a straw man argument when
you're knowingly and willingly making
the service worse to prove a political
point well I think actually they
responded to category one and two calls
right across the country which obviously
category one is a heart attack um Kevin
choose the heart attack and straight
category one was unconscious and that is
what they that's what they would agree
they do and actually in some areas and
I'm sure you'll have seen this as well
Harry we're talking to people on the
ground across the country but in some
areas the ambulance service provided
precisely because they were conscious
that they needed to make sure that it
was well serviced it was better than it
is on regular days when people have had
to win Paris
yeah
to police borders better than Border
Wars was the other the other great
example of that activities to prepare on
the ambulance they recognize it's an
operational picket line it's that's how
they describe it and just on the
substantive point in the times as well
that schools can't plan uh after unions
told members to keep their head teachers
in the dark about whether they're taking
part the rules are the Neu is required
by law to provide schools with the
number of members that it is calling on
to take strike action in each workplace
the union does not have to provide the
names of members I put it tomorrow Dr
Mary bow said that makes it impossible
for people to plan you don't know if
you've got a sports teacher or a
chemistry teacher on and she said it has
to be that way to prevent any
intimidation to try to persuade people
not to strike so that that's the reason
it happens she said
she would say that they wouldn't she
that's she's the one that's agitating
and organizing this it's ridiculous they
are stretching they are already pretty
potted straight strike laws to the
absolute limit and if they were in any
other European country our nearest
neighbors be it France Spain Belgium and
Holland they would be on the much
stricter rules for striking and no one's
suggesting they're some sort of you know
sort of Southern South American
dictatorship that doesn't allow trade
unions yeah so Harry what was the when
might this minimum service level
legislation actually pass and will it
stop anything of these dates we've
already got in there
because because the government of Dilly
dallied for for years and months this
was a Manifesto commitment in the 2015
election I think to do that there was a
much tougher strike laws um advocated by
David Cameron in 2015 in his Manifesto
that he did a deal with with the TUC to
drop if they became out enthusiastically
impact his remain campaign so the
government have only got themselves to
blame for dithering over years
um but in slightly better times when
there were when there were fewer strikes
um we haven't really seen industrial
action like this since until 2011 and
2013 period
um it all then sort of quietened off all
this legislation was put on the back
burner or sort of dropped or negotiated
away and now the chickens have come home
to roost and the government's playing
catch up okay well and meantime uh Rishi
sunac in the Metro we saw him um in
Darlington uh suggesting why he can't
settle pay which is because the real
inflation at real evil rather is
inflation um saying to the assembled
audience there Pippa that if we have the
same or similar levels inflation in the
years ago years time rather no
department will have any money to spend
it um and yet he is putting a bit of
money towards Emergency Care in the in
the National Health Service a two-year
plan for that with a plan for Primary
Care still to come how do you think he
did today
well um I listened in I wasn't obviously
in Darlington uh today like some of my
colleagues uh but I listened in to his
extensive q a with members of
um uh members of the audience who were
primarily health workers so we had
Community Pharmacists and nurse training
nurses
um uh and various others that were that
were sort of on the front line and the
consistent theme throughout was that
they didn't have enough money to keep
the services going and I was very struck
by the community pharmacist who was the
second
um person to ask a question and of
course Rishi made the point that his mom
was a community pharmacist and
pharmacists were very dear to his heart
and it didn't really have any answers to
the suggestion that the the
um the sector might basically was like
was on its knees and you're going to see
pharmacies closing right across right
across the country
um I mean there is a really there's a
huge long-term systemic issue here in
that it's not just about cash obviously
the correct what's been discussed at the
moment is pay Rises for people for staff
that are really struggling that have
been struggling for years with um with
um real-time pay cards and it's also
about retention of those staff in the
Health Service but there's also a
broader systemic issue about the NHS
which given our aging population and the
demands that have been placed on it with
both the pandemic and flu over this
winter but um you know pandemic over the
last couple of years
um increasingly is facing costs uh and
and whether you know how you address
those in terms of in terms of Reform and
what that reform looks like and
obviously you've got the labor party
saying that they're prepared to use
private um hospitals in order to get
those huge waiting lists down but not
beyond that and the government
um the government is you know also
striving to reduce waiting lists
um and you know there's definitely sort
of a bigger picture here when on the one
hand you have uh Steve Barclays saying
that he wants to he wants to increase
productivity chess presumably meaning
the systems but then of course you know
there's people who are working right on
the front line who interpret that as
being you know an attack on them who are
often working beyond their shift
patterns and you know if you're sort of
on the front line in a e or GP surgery
then you're really seeing you know
you're seeing everything
um and um and then sort of feeling sort
of Under Siege really from the
government and it's um you know it's
it's sort of a bigger picture than the
sort of a media one here yeah
he did make the point that more money is
going into the NHS and social care than
ever before the pie is as big as it's
ever been but as you said the the demand
the pressure is certainly growing um but
he was also asked wasn't he well it was
up there about how he handled the
sucking of of the party chair
um uh yes I was Swift to sacum it was
appropriate
Etc Harry yeah it wasn't I mean it
wasn't that as weird he could have fired
him a week before when it was clear that
um the dreams the highway had
um had misled at best uh numerous um
administrations in it in not declaring
that he had paid his penalty
um you know his statement that he put
out I think it was a week on Saturday
ago made pretty clear uh and it was less
let it let it be known that he was quote
livid with Nadim zahar we could have
fired him then but again went through
the book part of the thing slightly as a
party management
um tool really and he is a sort of
stickler for the rules when he's not
getting fined for eating cake and and
driving a seat belts on but he claims to
be a stick to the rules and loves
process so I think he wanted to go
through the um go through the motions of
this new independent advisor which is
yeah aren't Honorable in some ways but
also politically quite naive because I
think Downing Street realized pretty
quickly over the weekend that another
week of this and it's really going to
start biting which you soon act so hence
why we saw that extraordinary sort of 7
A.M brexit breakfast firing on Sunday
morning he got there in the end let's
put it that way yes and I just wonder
listening to him today and what what you
said about being politically naive
whether we're still seeing a prime
minister who thinks like a Chancellor
pepper
yes well he doesn't seem to have that
political Instinct that I think some of
his predecessors have had and you know I
think when you look at
um for example when he came in uh to
power and he made that pledge that his
government would be exemplified by by uh
professionalism integrity and I think it
was accountability at every level
um he felt that that was really
important to do to restore trust in the
institution of Government after the
Boris Johnson era and and he was
probably right but the problem he's
facing is that you know his first 100
days when he wants to be talking about
bringing down NHS waiting lists and
tackling small boats and anti-strike
legislation and the economy instead
um he's having to divert a lot of
airspace a lot of oxygen a little
political capital and dealing with a
series of scandals property um so you
know we had Gavin Williamson getting
sacked over bullying obviously Dominic
Rabb his depth prime minister is under
investigation for bullying allegations
and we're expecting the result of that
very broad inquiry soon and um and then
the latest is of course Harvey so he's
struggling to get a hearing yeah first
hundred days is it this week I've
forgotten already it was all a blur
posted his trust wasn't it which day
Thursday
and it's the anniversary of brexit
tomorrow isn't it quite a week for
anniversary how are you celebrating
could you put on tonight and not
tomorrow anyway lots coming up um did
Vladimir Putin really threaten to kill
Boris Johnson the former prime minister
claims he did we'll talk about that in
just a moment
thank you
[Music]
you are watching The Press preview with
me once again pipakura and Harry Cole
from the guardian and the sun Harry we
go to the front page of the Metro uh no
time to lie
um people probably heard the story
already but could you explain the story
to us and where we're up we're up to
with it
yeah I've been a proper uh proper spat
this one Boris Johnson in a documentary
about the run-up of the Ukraine war
revealed in in February last year I
think one of his sort of 11th Hour calls
to the to the Kremlin
um trying to convince Putin to to to to
to not invade Ukraine obviously lots of
leaders were making these calls at the
time sort of diplomatic sort of hopes
were fading as those troop movements
built up if you cast your memory back to
that time and um pujin Johnson alleges
um made a remark whether it was a threat
or a some sort of sick joke
um remains to be seen of you know if I
wanted to kill you I could do it with a
missile in in minutes now obviously
Johnson is not the sort of thing that a
prime minister or any world leader would
say in office but has let it slip to
this documentary
um subsequently now the Kremlin have
denied this like they deny gassing
children in Syria or the war crimes in
butcher or indeed deny even calling the
invasion of Ukraine Awards special
military operation but such is the uh
still long-running delusion and sort of
derangement anything to do with Boris
Johnson in some parts of the media
um that actually you know you had Alison
Campbell today parrot in the Kremlin
lions and people siding with Putin over
over Johnson which um I think shows you
just how far down the rabbit hole's gone
and I think it's quite astonishing
actually that a paper was August and
esteemed as the Metro have decided to
Parrot Kremlin propaganda on their front
page for the sake of a cheap political
point
well onto another newspaper as August
and with the steam to the Daily Star I'm
talking about toilet roll in fact
um so popular in lockdown it ran out and
now people are cutting back it seems
Pippa briefly
yes well you know I'm sure I wasn't I
wasn't the only one to have sort of
several packets stashed on top of the
Wardrobe during the pandemic in case we
ran out
um and uh yeah now it looks like it
doesn't quite say why the star we've the
cost of living crisis is it that we're
talking about it seems to be fancy
fancyly roll as they put it yeah
budget budget recycled instead which
sounds about right to me I hope it's not
recycled recycled paper sorry I'm gonna
stop both of you time to go uh papakura
and haricol do you apologize then what
came okay